antonio analiza sus estadísticas de
basketball la tabla siguiente muestra un
modelo de probabilidad de los resultados
para sus próximos dos tiros libres en la
tabla nos muestran varios resultados de
ambos tiros libres y la probabilidad
correspondiente si falla ambos tiros es
de 0.2 si acierta solamente un tiro es
de 0.5 y si acierta ambos tiros la
probabilidad es de 0.1 es este un modelo
válido de probabilidad pausa en el vídeo
y traten de responder a esta pregunta
primero veamos qué es lo que hace que un
modelo de probabilidad sea válido
inicialmente la suma de todas las
probabilidades debe ser igual a 100% por
lo que definitivamente tenemos que
verificar esto lo segundo es que ninguna
de las probabilidades debe tener un
valor negativo podemos tener un
escenario con una probabilidad de 0%
pero ninguno con probabilidades
negativas todas estas probabilidades son
positivas por lo que cumplimos con el
segundo punto en el que ninguna
probabilidad debe
ser negativa pero la suma del 100% 0.2
0.5 20.7 más 0.1 nos da 0.8 o el 80% no
llega al 100% por lo que no es un modelo
válido de probabilidad para que sea
válido la suma de todos los escenarios
debe ser igual a 100% aquí no es el caso
y si estas probabilidades sumarán 101 %
tampoco sería un modelo válido así que
simplemente escribimos no hagamos otro
problema nos dicen eres un
extraterrestre visites el planeta tierra
y abdou cesc 97 gallinas 47 vacas y 77
humanos después eliges aleatoriamente a
un ser vivo de la tierra de entre tus
muestras para experimentar en el cadáver
tiene la misma probabilidad de ser
seleccionado crea un modelo de
probabilidad para mostrar qué tan
probable es que selecciones cada tipo de
ser vivo terrícola escribe
tus respuestas como una fracción o como
un decimal redondeado a la centésima más
cercana en el ejemplo anterior queríamos
saber si el modelo de probabilidad que
nos mostraban era válido aquí nos piden
que construyamos un modelo válido como
hacemos eso bueno la probabilidad de
estimada de elegir una gallina va a ser
la fracción que estamos muestreando que
son nuestras gallinas debido a que todos
los seres vivos de aquí tienen la misma
probabilidad de ser elegidos 97 de los
97 más 47 más 77 seres vivos son
gallinas aquí será igual esto 97 47 77
aquí es 21 llevamos dos y dos más nueve
más 47 nos da 22 y la suma es 221 la
fracción es 97 entre 221 nos dicen que
podemos poner la respuesta como fracción
así que así lo haremos cuál es la
probabilidad de las vacas 47 de los 221
seres vivos son vacas así
esta es la probabilidad de elegir una
vaca y la fracción de los humanos es 77
entre 221 esta es una distribución de
probabilidad válida para saberlo tenemos
que sumar todas estas si sumamos todas
estas fracciones tenemos que todos los
denominadores son 221 así que sumamos
los numeradores y ya sabemos que 97 más
47 más 77 es igual a 221 la suma es
igual a 1 y ninguna de estas cantidades
es negativa así que esta es una
distribución de probabilidad válida